Wait,
but actually wait. Because if Trump is elected back into office,
then his administration
is supportive of cutting funding to essential services
like service, Social Security,
which is known for helping disabled workers and retirees.
Meaning that retirement
probably not gonna be possible for a lot of working Americans.
You see, instead
the Trump administration
is supportive of giving tax cuts to the ultra wealthy.
You know, that top 1%.
And this has been sold to all of us
as an imperative way of boosting the economy,
but all its done is further widen the income inequality gap.
So I guess what I'm asking you is
before you go to the polls,
take a second wait and make sure that you have all the facts
about what you're actually voting for.